bonjour à tous madame monsieur bonjour
bon appétit si vous êtes à table
aujourd'hui notre émission face à la
première est consacrée à ce soulèvement
populaire sévèrement réprimées qui a eu
lieu durant une semaine à partir du 22
septembre 1870 passé à la postérité sous
le nom de l'insurrection du sud pour
évoquer ce pan de notre histoire deux
invités deux historiens d'abord armand
nicolas bonjour bonjour alors lettre
l'auteur en 1970 du point me livre
complet sur les événements factuel et
l'analyse de ce soulèvement général
livre qui a été d'ailleurs réédité les
gens lui font ça joli fond ça bonjour
bonjour bonjour vous êtes donc le connu
dans le monde de l'éducation et des
présidents du comité glorifier septembre
1870 pour vous interroger avec moi le
rédacteur en chef de martinique 1ère
radio jean marc partie bonjour jean marc
ouimet jouera les mangera à toutes et à
tous l'émission est réalisée par gilles
luisi alors avant de rentrer dans le vif
du sujet nous allons évoquer avec vous
deux faits qui ont marqué l'actualité
d'abord les propos de nicolas sarkozy et
qui lors d'un meeting lundi à
franconville dans le val d'oise en
france a déclaré que vous devenez
français vos ancêtres sont dès que vous
devenez français vos ancêtres sont
gaulois nous ne nous contenterons plus
d'une intégration qui ne marche plus
nous exigeons la simulation armonico une
réaction je ne suis pas assez ou puis de
cette intervention monsieur sarkozy
avait là une occasion à mettre aux
prises d'adopter des positions de ce
genre
donc le cul par surprise mais je suis en
colère
comme je l ai été à chaque fois où on a
abordé ce sujet dans les milieux
gouvernementaux août
rapprochez-vous
2 - peu plus rapproché votre chaise s'il
vous plaît monsieur armand nicolas alors
nous sommes en direct bien sûr et vous
nous voyez puisque c'est un radio filmée
également alors poursuivre et oui alors
ce qui ce qui m'a choqué ce qui me
choque surtout c'est que il ya une
véritable tentative dans les milieux
dirigeants général une véritable
tentative de refaire l'histoire de
offert l'histoire d'une autre manière
before est un gourmand et en
caricaturant les faits réels qui que
nous avons eu à observer et à essayer de
tout le trafic et d'histoire en quelque
sorte pour la mettre plus à la portée
des projets politiques des dirigeants de
la france il ya mis à part entre
monsieur fillon candidat à la présidence
de la république monsieur fillon pour la
mecque l'esclavagé tout ça n'était
qu'une péripétie
oui la serbie qui a permis aux qui a
permis aux populations esclavagisés
d'accéder à la civilisation est en
quelque sorte le cavage était une sorte
de le contacter de civilisation qui a
joué pour parfaitement en faveur des
esclaves des milieux ce qu est ce qu est
la vie
je c'est une c'est une révision je veux
dire ou complète de l'histoire
alors là une visio nisme comme la même
que monsieur le pen déclare que les les
chambres à gaz étaient les détails bas
monsieur sarkozy monsieur fillon et
cetera aussi il ya un détail le détail
bien c'est que la clinique par exemple a
été réduite à dix pendant quatre jours
mais pendant plus de deux siècles et ce
qui s'est passé après d'ailleurs 1148
moi je crois bien qu'ils avaient pas mal
le sait qu'elle est de what's going on
sait qu'elles sont répartis alors
justement ça tombe bien puisque sa
transition nous évoquons aujourd'hui
comme un disions cette célèbre
insurrection du sud alors les passer ça
manque ce mouvement populaire est passé
à la possibilité quand même si l'option
du sud parce qu'il s'est cantonné c'est
pas deux c'est par une histoire aussi de
la martinique on verra dans quelle
circonstance tout à l'heure mais aussi
aux anciens qui a lieu à compter du 22
septembre 1870 alors j'ai dix élèves en
fait c'est une mi temps parce qu'en
réalité et appelle martine qui est
aujourd'hui ils savent exactement ce qui
s'est passé à ce moment là est donc
aujourd'hui nous sommes là pour savoir
premièrement ce qui s'est passé ce qui
se passe durant l'insurrection
tout de suite après avec les procès et
puis pourquoi ça nous interpelle
aujourd'hui en coin dont certains
historiens parmi lesquels vous êtes les
représentants mais nicolas jean louis
france à mener d'autres opérations
également des sociologues ou autre qu'un
travail sur cette période pense que
disent que c'est pour comprendre la
société martiniquaise aujourd'hui du
début du xxième siècle il faut se
référer à ce qui s'est passé pendant et
surtout après l'insurrection comme si en
quelque sorte les fondements de notre
société contemporaine se sont
cristallisées se sont cimentées à part
entière de ces événements allons tout
d'abord pour ceux qui ne savent pas ce
qu'ils ont oublié aussi qu'ils savent
peu rappelons effet rapidement avec vos
gens nous font ça sens et dans beaucoup
de détails puisque nous avons eu du vent
toute cette semaine l'occasion d'en
parler avec plusieurs historiens
notamment
rappelons tout de même ça me dit comment
démarre cette fameuse insurrection du
sud le 22 septembre 1970 de plus
précisément ce qui s'est passé dans les
mois précédents oui mais avant d'en de
la synopsis de la chronologie
il faut quand même se rappeler la
violence coloniale et l'utopie
civilisatrice qui tombe exactement dans
les propos de mettre en mots nicolas et
des propos de sarkozy de fillon la
france n'a jamais reconnu la dynamique
du nom son histoire la contesterait la
colonisation n'a pas reconnu les
massacres de sétif ni à madagascar et
jusqu'à présent fin de la guerre la
guerre contre les indépendantistes
malgache réseau et dentistes finale
juillet c'était même pas les pokes des
platines c'est mieux puisque 40 ans 40
sernageomin petit une manifestation de
la libération devenue le rhume est mis
sur un 5-2 et donc la france n'a jamais
reconnu et quand on parle de l'histoire
l'esclavagé puis les laisse quand même
des passes et un statut c'est
panafricain et a dit que en fait ils ont
choisi fier à 13 du code noir et une
situation sociale nadine ce qu une boîte
de production qui l'ont remis à plat ce
que le mot d'options esclavagiste et
quand on regarde le lot de l'ouverture
des jeux olympiques
ça veut brésil le commentaire du
présentateur le français qui disait race
à l'esclavagé
le brésil s'est développée doxi blessé
de la même veine pour révisionnisme
doublé qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
l'histoire de 1170 de 6,1 du sud
évidemment elle est aussi occulté
occulter à dire que ceux qui
actuellement se passe dans les radios et
télévisions
alors on doit poser les événements
il a rappelé que roman de février 1970
un incident qui peut sembler banal
pénales se déroulent mais qui n'est pas
banaliser du tout il s'agit du jeune
commerçant nous sommes 22 ans après
l'abolition ne serait ce qu'avec tout le
monde est supposé être libre
s'il croyait alors citoyens c'est quoi
est ce important et donc un jeune
commerçant une autre jeune artiste d'un
jeune artisan du marin lubin croisé sur
un chemin sur un sentier étroit
alors qu'il est à cheval c'est un autre
équipage alors exactement le 10 février
le pôle urbain kit artisans
d'autres noms tati sans famille connue
de le sud travaille sur grand format ray
le grand format 11,6 et de cuvettes
cannière 90 pas oui entre maca pointent
le bout du marais
ils attendent creuser un canal puisque l
usine du marine doit s'ouvrir en 1871
attention un canal un kanaky ganso
sportello deux pilotes verrue du marais
et là sur cette route où il travaille
avec sa famille arrive un fonctionnaire
s'appelle pellec dans le vrai qu à
cheval qui estime que le mail laisse pas
suffisamment de passe ou pas c est le
fouette le bain et qu'est ce qu'il fait
y porte est évidemment politique du
canton du bas rhin pour plaire et le
très doué mais les deux parties ont
porté plainte
engagez vous résultat quelques mois plus
tard comme n'y a pas eu de procès en
avril
qu'est-ce qui fait louper ils vont
compte ce jeune homme c'est un nouveau
challenge dans là haut qui descendent
des producteurs des yeux clos
connaissent le marin être arrêté cocada
et vanquish
il y avait lui qui a dû manger ses
branchies et un coin pellec de l'autre
est d'accord et ont coupé beke qui
l'avait qui s'appelait bien joué ce
travail tout est légal aux tec de mexès
doctor who des homos des habits lot
évidemment procès est lui bien condamné
à cinq ans de bail merlos important
parce qu'il y avait deux législations en
martinique à l'époque entre 1,5 entre 48
et 70 m2 d'installations une hélistation
pour les colons et le blanc et
organisations pour les descendants
d'esclaves
les nouveaux afrique est arrivé un peu
le congo et les indiens et to tatou
descend d'africains ou congo ont été
condamnés à 5 ans est automatiquement au
bail
alors quand la même période il ya un
colon calmes et fruité qu'avec tué
martinique 1 il a été acquitté et vous
comprenez bien que de la population du
sud de la martinique
marieville et ploc évidemment c'est un
bloqueur c'était justice évidemment
cette injustice ciblée est liée en
grande partie à une situation très
particulière qui est que 48 et 70 a
donné un match alors cet incident entre
l'humain et pelles et de lautrec et au
gie de maintenant lubin condamné au
bagne mais bon qu'est ce qui explique
tout de suite il ya une sentiment de
colère généralisée qui parle des pilotes
du marin et qui finalement de proche en
proche gagnant une bonne partie du pays
par mon nicolas qu'est ce qui explique
ce que tu disais naissant c'est après 48
on est censé être libre mais on lui 1878
s'il veut aller ce sont des vingt années
devait vingt années je dirais de deux
processeurs l'âgisme c'est à dire que l'
esclavage ni pan colonies dans les
mentalités de certains n'est pas
escamoté et c'est d'ailleurs lui joue
pas mal de points à martinique et en
période de changement de mutation alors
1177 majorité de la population est née
sous l'espace a connu les ce cas c'est
ça c'est ça c'est ça le régime qui
s'installe après et qui va durer de
pratiquement de 1850 à millas 1870
c'est le régime napoléonien le régime de
napoléon iii pas le premier de trois
enfants et ce régime sera une sorte de
prendre le jeu
est ce pour un logement loué gym puis
cédant et l'apéro il à coutras périodes
où il ya eu véritablement un petit
souffle d'un qui s'était salir et un
manque inique
après l'abolition c est les quelques
mois qui ont suivi devant le n 1 c'est à
dire l'année 49 où on a essayé
d'appliquer les décret d'abolition du 27
avril
parce que à cette lady grey sur deux 48
ne sont pas seulement une simple
déclaration d'abolition 1 c'est pas un
texte où il y avait une fois je me
disais ça va j'ai dabul et cetera c'est
un texte 7e aux jo ce qui confortait
27-27 décret qui connaissait sociétique
qui modifie considérablement la société
après le prêt après l'abolition par
exemple par exemple sur le plan de
l'éducation
il était décidé que chaque commune
aurait une école publique gratuite
une poule est égale l'argent et pour les
filles et enfin tout pas en question en
france continentale alors on venir
il faut plus aux normes on va on va
quand même quelque chose de connaître
les causes profondes des causes
profondes sont multiples c'est pas
seulement parce qu'il ya eu un échange
de coups et un jugement
abusif c'est parce que il y a d'autres
choses plus profondes qui ont perduré
après 1848 alors nous allons nous avons
l'exemple suivant c'est pour vous
quelles raisons ou bien lu mais at-il
été faute et c'est parce qu'on estime
que le esclave ou best of
bailly c'est un individu qui est
inférieur aux dominateur aux colons
blancs européens et les et doit
se recourber se plier laissez passer à
lui et cetera à celui ci ou à celui là
c'est noc une trêve c'est une chose qui
est très forte c'est à dire ces faits de
racisme permanent qui met en relief la
domination du maître et lorsque le mec
n'est plus mais qu'il est mais d'une
autre manière et il n'a plus il n'est
plus maître d'esclaves mais il est il
est le maître de la situation
alors il ya ça qui est très fort et et
dans le dos qui qui galvanise quelque
sorte le mécontentement de la population
et il ne faut pas oublier que la système
économique mis en place après
l'abolition est un véritable si simple
le travail forcé il ya eu il ya eu une
espèce ou un peu une débandade après 48
où les esclaves non plus voulu continuer
à jouer le jeu de l'esclavagé et où ils
sont allés se débrouiller etc
mais il a manqué de manoeuvre et il a
fallu dès la fin lui introduire une
nouvelle meilleure alors en est ne
donnons c'est très important
une limite à une immigration africaine
d'abord longtemps nous les congo les
fameux congo parce que eux ils vont
participer à la solution pour les voilà
pourquoi les il ya une amie d'une
immigration hindous qui a déjà commencé
qui était pourtant et qui est une sorte
de forme déguisée de la technique
négrière et c'est pas que trois
personnes ce sont des milliers de
nouveaux mille pièces de nouveaux qui
sont contre lui qui se trouvera deux
situations d'exploitation féroce et de
misère atroce
ce qui fait que vous avez toute cette
partie de la population qui est concerné
et qui sera qui sera agissante au moment
où les événements vont se précipiter
alors il ne faut pas oublier ce qu'il
faut il faut pas sonner voyez il faut
penser à tout ça produit ou c'est pas
seulement ni son ambition de bien de
calotte et que c'est un système profond
de la misère d'exploitation de
domination de mépris qui était salée
pendant veut plus des années et que ce
que c'est en quelque sorte que les
carottes qui se sont échangées c'est la
goutte qui a fait déborder le vase
alors aujourd'hui fonsat qui dirige le
mouvement va sauter quelques étapes qui
dirige ce mouvement en 1870 alors ce
qu'a dit armani collègue faisait pas
autant d éléments qui vont retenir si la
loi guesdon leur guidon kinois qui
organise de travail et foncé sur
invitation à ça c'est très important
la langue d'un pause les passes comme
l'afrique du sud ça dit que le passeport
oui tu as dit que chaque 6 3 et ils ont
en 1 156 il ya eu 40 mais pas de
délivrer c'est un document qui obligeait
à tous les à ses esclaves d'avoir ce
papier sur lui sans quoi s'il est pas ce
papier était arrêté et la gamme ans
d'âge du vagabondage et envoyées dans un
camp travail gratuit
d'autre part j'avais mise en place sur
pellicule un espace hier sadi travail
associée et si le contrat n'a pas été
renouvelé en mairie par année tout de
suite ont été arrêtés on paie un impôt
par des pavois le pass et comme papa le
contrat face à l'impôt c'est que des
nouveaux et ontario s'est enfoncée si
vous voulez la différence qu'il ya entre
l'esclavagé et cette période de travail
forcé ciblé n'est pas grand même s'il ya
eu 48 ne pas le vexer et une frustration
cette prestation de la population et
doux lorsque la sphère l'ubs un arrêt en
fin et que le mec est codé qui publiait
d'habitation mounia pilotes et assesseur
au tribunal
et lorsqu'il revient après l'appel après
les deux procès l'appel revient à la
pelote et se vante d'avoir fait
condamner un au bayer la
population si vous dès la jonction entre
les faits de février la condamnation
bail et cette situation sociale et
économique exceptionnelle pendant cette
période et les doigts qui les
accompagnent à fait que lors de la peau
quand la promotion atomique
d'accord le mercredi 21 septembre à la
deuxième en importance en disgrâce en
visitant ces dates avaient pourtant
c'est que là le second tapis moeurs
napoléon iii et battu à sedan à sedan et
les saisonniers
il est fait prisonnier par la crise là
puisque encore même pas c'est pas encore
la mène c'est un petit un état de futur
allemagne qu'on remettra parce que
quelqu'un a man who est battu qu'est ce
que les gens disent les gens disent deux
choses et donc très vieux on apprend
qu'ils la france a été battue
on apprend que le public est programmée
et à fort de france
le cad arrive on savait déjà depuis
depuis février
depuis pas débuter début de but de 9
septembre on savait par un câble ou
venant de la havane passant par ce matin
que la nacelle a dit m côté déco mais
parce que le régime n'a pas lé derrière
il ya 12-1 santé avant de france arrivé
l'information est tout de suite le matin
du 2 septembre afin de fausses
informations dans la brique et
l'après-midi à yviers pelote à 14 heures
le meilleur que ça peut connaître de
venaco pour commencer public est là une
foule devant le mr hessel foule réclame
deux choses évidemment
coli bérubé vive les prussiens et vu la
république
d'accord d'accord hélas les premiers
incidents
le maire n'a pas il a que 4 5 g dames
avec lui cinq gendarmes ma présence est
le même et se négocie et arrivent tel
gars qui était une dirigeants à l'autre
alors voilà le portrait dirigeants comme
troyes dijon popotin c'était le gars de
gatineau la gamme de galettes galette
puisqu'il semblerait que le la main de
tels gains étaient et esclave de maison
chez les galettes au marais et que là le
fils est il gay évidemment a appris
métiers de l'aude au fesf
et c'est maintenant parce que tes gars
c'est quand même un moins bon pied pour
l'époque une petit gars que mes mains
publiques rgpp exempts ce qui était
aussi bouché
donc ils se déplacent et matignon a dit
un vendeur de cétacés de précampagne du
sud pour acheter et vendre et d'agrégats
c'est connu il y avait aussi donc ils
arrivent ils arrivent avec la sève
négocié avec le maire il veut négocier
la libération de deux ans n'ont que
quelques uns si tu n'es pas seule il y
avait une sorte de club véritable route
pagne à reconstituer avec celui et qui
était en quelque sorte qu'une bouchée la
préparation est de mouvements d'eau
qu'ils devaient se faire on ne savait
pas quand mais n'était dans les locaux
qui étaient entrés alors docteur alioune
saison avec ses amis sarkozy et à la
mairie devant l'église la place de
l'église en vain puisqu'il n'ya pas mais
se fait des sommes effectivement et ils
veulent les prières vu la république et
libérez-le hubert parallèlement il dit
le bo est occupé et on va chercher des
armes
il ya un problème un colon becker qui
s'appelle la force marin qui aime tant
qu'un boutique emden pharmacie ont
trouvé des armes chez lui et le maire
le maire devient que leurs collègues
venant comme qu'est ce qu'il fait y la
lettre du gouverneur
moi je de luan plus dit il ya des
incidents vient pilotes mais le nombre
de gendarmes est insuffisant le
gouverneur
qu'est ce qu'il fait il y avait dit gr10
au maire de sète 15 personnes et d'avoir
un pilote il ya eu un prix au premier
affrontement entre les la troupe de tels
gains et six militaires de mantra moquer
d'un sas le premier jour et le deuxième
jour évidemment quand on encore sentant
monter la pression
c'est un trop long et blanc il
démissionne il propose comme air goût
des ormeaux et pomponne qui sont 2000
être du goût de réglisse et pourquoi
aussi à villars à la villa c'est
important vide ancien instituteur et
c'est lui qui avait créé à huis clos
devant le club des tropiques entre
guillemets où on trouve toute cette
jeunesse les doigts vite et d'égérie
germain et c est dans ce club de
tropiques d'accord parce qu'il faut dire
que reggae plantes qu'il n'y a plus
d'école des écoles ont été fermées les
données indiquent au diable dirigé par
les serbes et les hommes ont été fermées
il ya petit vention donc c'était firme
est donc à l'économie et donc dans ce
club de jeunes du bout se chuchotait
évidemment tout ce qui a été fait pour
libérer le bain tu as dit les soussous
les deux petits sets serrés monsieur
chute aussi des propos que rapporter aux
religieuses il sûr de cluny qui disent
que oui ces jeunes et qui sont unis
samedi soir et il disait que voilà les
blancs assez fou de nous et il faut
qu'on soit conçu comme ces domaines etc
c'était donc ça y est une sorte de comme
dire que le mouvement silencieux et un
mur de huy
subversive qui est keith un partenaire
sous les surplus qui n'a pas de travail
forcément luminy monde soit d'accord et
tout de suite on continue tout s'est
rapidement donc le lendemain rebelote
évidemment tel gars arrivent dans cette
fois-ci armée et arrive la troupe de la
caille provient de rigal cazalet acquis
deux groupes alors qu'ils accueillent
l'accueil c'est un minable qui n'a pas
qu'il a pété cela dit on n'a jamais été
connu l'esclave qui le domine ses
parents sont d'origine bretonne
par contre à 48 lacalle 67 ans non plus
qui gênent pas quant à 48 il est connu
déjà avec le père match hésitant match
dit qu à la culotte qui avait ainsi fini
13e oui parce que ces faits qui prouvent
qu'ils prenaient à libération des
esclaves
c'est l'égalité entre toutes ans était
en train de traiter cette course est la
caille et décrit maria pratique avec sa
hiérarchie puisque derrière cet outil
fiscal avant de revenir quelques exaltés
débutants et l'accueil à 48 d'un jeu de
robert parlant déjà proposé la
séparation des terrains dont elle était
connue la caille et il arriva que sa
troupe de régal et il ya une conjonction
entre la coupe de dégâts et la coupe de
la canne et à ce moment ils partent pour
la mauny la merde les accompagner
premier à prendre le meilleur vin on
trouve pas à godet ils reviennent et roy
patron lendemain et pas vers l'harmonie
égouts des biens disparus
si son serviteur jauge qui est là et des
qui se vit tout de suite et les gens
s'attaquent goudé a rejoint lemon et
toutes ses troupes par ben le monde mon
escapade en escale et là on retrouve
goudé cachés dans les jambes à quoi est
il éxécuté évidemment garder les détails
il a exécuté
merci assez sévèrement disent vraiment
alors maintenant on parle de ça de
manière calme et en fait c'est il ya des
l'année comme un device est quasiment
guerre civile contre le gouverneur de
martinique contre le maire de rivière
pilote armés avec des armes d'un peu
partout on a trouvé chez les békés peu
partout dans les mairies flambeau en
termes de commandes y donne de toute
nature donc c'est vraiment une
population en marche qui va 20
habitations harmonie qui marche vers la
mairie qui s'est exercé sa peau de la
bande occupé la ville st c'est pas une
manifestation de rue passante population
qui est malheureusement ici je vois pas
ce que c'est ainsi que le résultat qui
est qui n'a pas les moyens qui n'a pas
les moyens militaires qui fusaient
susceptibles d'affronter les troupes qui
vont se retrouver en face d'elle alors
tellement la jouer les femmes ont joué
le jeu en tant que ces deux coups le
groupe d'un tel gâchis énorme et qui
m'ont appelé l'armée de garantie bien
organisés parce qu'il est mais rares
étaient bien discret que tous ensemble
et ça fait quand même
et de votre côté l'armée de la caille
que dieu nous a donnée mais la caille
c'est quand même une ged est considéré
en direct dans les bois c'est quelqu'un
d'un proie si vous cliquiez
psychologique sur la population si la
boulette
il faut savoir qu'en 48 heures ils ont
pour ils ont pu mobiliser plus de 1000
personnes debout de diablo ii samedi qu'
un an avant l'argent la rue préparation
et pendant huit les l'insurrection
s'étend rapidement entre le 22 et le 24
l'ensemble du sud est touché par le su
agen tadieu marais s'étendent vauclin
c'est plus bien salée s'est inscrit du
coup c'est vraiment que nous avons le
l'ex entraîneur dé augmente a dit on
touche le fond ça touchés et lors du
procès ce qu'ils sont les actes du
tribunal de guerre qui nous donne
quelques idées soulève ce qui a parlé
des cris de les ponts et jusqu aux gones
les gens disaient que tel gars beaucoup
de supputations
avant l'insurrection était connu comme
on l'était cronje lamentin était connu à
trinité donc il suffit de quelques
signal pour exaucer mobilisés après tout
le monde sait week-end mobilisant c'est
quand je vois la mobilisation générale à
48 heures et le nombre de communes
touchées par les sucs sur dur casey
bagasse mutation etc qui a touché donc
on peut très bien aller pour patiner
what that need you net - viennent pas de
route c'était des sentiers ou pas de
créer un billet que nous sommes la place
étaient prêtes dégâts mais deux amants
il y avait du talent et organisé qui
fonctionnait alors le rôle des femmes us
alors atteint de justesse et juste pour
rappeler parce que c'est important comme
jeudi intervient alors on parle de ça
calmement mais ça c'est une agression
c'est un slogan des chefs politiques et
les chefs militaires qui se sont armés
qui ont préparé leur coup qui ont
attendu le moment propice qui arrivait
avec les incidents posant lui-même et
c'est ce fonctionnaire coller la fidh a
de l'envié aux populations en armes ou
des armes et se soulève dans la moitié
des communes et bien signé aujourd'hui
la moitié de la population peut 5000
personnes alors allez encore ses côtés à
l'époque d'après des statistiques
puisque sa fiabilité que c'est bien
l'avis de la plus importante et qui
historiquement a toujours été le centre
et l'est de l'agitation des soins je
loue pour attirer faut pas encore que
c'est le calmer
très bien il y assez sévèrement qui se
déroule à saint pierre et il y à des
manoeuvres manifestations populaires qui
se déroule à ça c'est bien toi parce que
il ya dans le temps tout ce mouvement il
ya un fonctionnaire français
métropolitains c'est le lycée l'heure
qu'il est même d'origine aristocratique
c'est le compte de la grange la cour de
la gauche quelqu'un fonctionnaires à ce
moment là et qui prend fait et cause
pour les esprits et il y là c'est gros
c'est aller venu il va il va intervenir
auprès de du gouverneur pour lui dire
attention aux livres 7 7 9 6 si bien que
dans le mouvement d'arrêt
on a failli s'arrêter parce qu'on a la
pression n'a conquis les titres en
question c'est sûr je connais fois ils
ont voulu fuir
non il y là nos riches à psa et cette
tablette est extrêmement actif
si la teneur il a non seulement entraîné
la population de saint pierre parce que
il s'est prononcé font clairement en
faveur des insurgés mais il il y en
avait à ce moment là le câble qui avait
commencé à fonctionner et il envoyait
des câbles partout en belgique fina ce
qui fait que le mouvement était connu un
niveau 1 niveau était en intérieur il ne
faut pas oublier à ce moment là c'est un
événement extrêmement important à
l'échelle mondiale c'est la commune de
paris c'est à dire de la première
révolution populaire qui s'il vous vient
rien qui s'est déroulée dans le monde et
est le nouveau gouvernement est trop
prises avec ces deux mouvements
populaires et en même temps ils km jeudi
30 sept
nous revenons sur le rôle des femmes
alors on fonce à la fin la déconvenue
ses luminaires souffre ici qu'en fait
son nom ses robes sus une fille du marin
c'est une jeune 17 ans est la plus
connue puisque la plus minable pas
déconner il ya une équipe qui fait
partie de l'apparat goût etc
alors les femmes sont très importantes
pourquoi les femmes sont très
importantes parce que les femmes enfin
quand on a fait en captant via pilotes
qui étaient dans l'étude en les archives
etc
c'était à la fois des cultivatrice du
couturier 1
il est vendeur sur les marchés donc ce
sont elles qui faisait circuler
l'information ont transporté
transportant des marchandises dans
différents présentent les titres
l'élimination fille par exemple quoique
peut-être connu captait dans les
hauteurs de dieu peut être que vous
créez et via pilote qui avait 17 ans
quittant 7 ont une insurrection avec son
compagnon si des et l on a calculé lors
du procès n'a calculé
quatre jours elle avait fait plus de 50
km
quand on a affaire pied à pied c'est à
dire quand on est content on avait vu à
vias à l'habitation au moulin qu'on a vu
au marin complet à un nouveau clic
sidérant dans les quatre jours où des
cinq chaînes du câble guédiguian on n'a
qu'à québec avec les plus fermés puis à
58 m peut être mon côté un peu mythique
dans cette affaire mais certainement
certainement à loyat elle ya madame
claire j'avais arrêté et la veille du
procès ces débats dès qu'on n'a jamais
retrouvé le procès de redon on va pas
tout à les inquiéter 11 madden clermont
n'a jamais retrouvé
d'accord il y avait une rosalie soleil
d'accord quitter comme une déclaration
qu'on a connue même si beau nier ces
deux tombes était un homme d'église ont
aussi d'accord est évidemment et les
femmes de l'armée de tels gains et de
l'armée de la can
les femmes alors qu'est-ce qu'ils
avaient tels qu'ils avaient installées
dans les coulées les ravines avec de
l'eau piment documentaires et des épices
qui devait envoyer ses ceci dans les
yeux des soldats et ils attaquaient avec
les sommes qu'ils avaient quittée donc
si vous voulez quand on regarde bien
l'autre du procès qu'on vue à tout à
l'heure
le nombre de femmes qui est a été le
monde de femmes qui était condamné à
mort par contumace deux femmes qui ont
été portées etc
on voit bien que des changements
importants de cette insurrection
en fait il s'agit bien d'une ex
impopulaires comme une insurrection mais
c'est un soulèvement comme ça
spontanément organisées même si après
pas spontanément une bonne partie de la
population a suivi mais il y avait une
véritable organisation bon évité avec
une direction politique politique oui ça
rigolait si le procès qui nous donnent
des indications
c'était que le club de guy pilote la
personnalité de tel gars la société de
la caille de villars de jérémy germain
éduque les jeunes qui étaient autour
d'eux montre bien qu'ils avaient une
idée quand même assez précise de ce
qu'ils exigeaient il exigeait comme
l'école gratuite
il exigeait sein de la première décision
et dpd ça ils exigent aussi la
suppression de la loi guesdon qui
obligeait travail forcé donc c'est
important
il suffisait ils demandent aussi la
suppression de deux tribunaux
celui que tous les courants et celui que
pour les descendants d'esclaves ou venez
et il y demande aussi l'arrêt aussi
parce que pendant cette période il ya
pile un conseil municipal c'était les
békés qui telle une équité qui dirigeait
les communes ils demandent le retour de
la démocratie donc les élections des
élections un leader puisque ça va être
supprimée ce qui situe la région
d'orléans d'accord et la caille donc de
partager tes seins et c'était pas mieux
parler de ces domaines et deux parce que
dans la tête une idée du gouverneur et
c'est parce que c'est important quand
j'étais étudiant je me souviens j'ai eu
il ya une vie dissolue niall 2000 avec
chants l'argent que depuis ces
spécialistes se cognant et je lus par
des sept sections c'est un remaniement
oui je n'en reviens tout autre chose et
il m'apporte un livre de l'otan shota
qui était ministre en chantant des sacs
et ministre des colonies ministre de
l'accident dans ses mémoires au pradet
l'insurrection et raconte les succès de
cette insurrection de masse qu'on a vue
d'accomplir tout à l'air etc avait
frappé les esprits comme des harmoniques
monsieur armand nicolas à paris etc cet
accident parce qu'un truc c'est kobe tu
as la populaire mais aussi il faut
savoir que cette même période il ya une
grande section kabylie en 1104 âgées
n'ont ni pourquoi ni les sondés étaient
déportés en guyane dans les antilles en
jalles et l'insurrection
si vous êtes kanaky taille thaï dont la
tête donné un bon de la tête il était un
des chefs kanak iv vous serez bien
contre l'ia france est important que le
cri de l'arrêt ce qui te tenue
dirigeants dirigeant nationaliste
portoricain qui a lancé un appel à
l'insurrection que d'espagnols et
cubains la guerre d'indépendance la
première a commencé donc si vous voulez
de par le monde il y avait quand même
qu'ils maîtrisent pas qu'il ressemble
beaucoup la note qu'il faut mettre un
c'est celle de la jamaïque 2165 la mort
est bien d'accord pour un incident si
mineur entre guillemets c'est à dire qui
tirait à hauteur de fiches à perdre à sa
banque un becquet courant terrain on tue
le boeuf et le gab a dit ban a expliqué
mme application bref vous un plus bas
rhin et tout de suite il a arrêté
et la population n'est ni charles procès
et les condamner et la population se
révolte se révolte et la répression
khouya liliane plus de mise et sa mort
qui était inquiétant et aujourd'hui
alors que
cette femme est juste moins de bien
évidemment de le parc des hauts de la
jamaïque
la statue de tous les dirigeantes chez
nous une satisfaction qu'on va voir qui
massive et est enterré à 80 et dans la
mémoire là pour des raisons
si vous voulez des raisons puisque rodez
alors deux raisons les souscriptions
comme tu dis a été de masse qui a touché
pratiquement toutes les communes puisque
même foi d'un france a eu des tentatives
des 110 saint-pierre le petit europe le
petit peuple de ses pieds
c'était un accident et on meurt pas se
croit bar live vous est ce important de
la porte la semaine yves calvi c dans
mes maîtres des barrages preuve alors
que ni ses raisons il y au salon savoir
qu'il ya deux avions le magicien
d'accord que tu n'as aucun avis et dans
d'artillerie tu remontes au canal
devient club pour bombarder l'a connu il
ya 2e david j'aime frégate qui doit le
canal de sainte-lucie d'accord pour
empêcher osé sujet de ses chats sainte
lucie de ce chapitre on retrouve en
totale il ya 1500 soldats et miliciens
et vient ajouter un commentaire
citation à ce moment là les milieux beke
de laventie clé milieu blanc de la
martinique ont demandé au gouverneur mc
dowell d'intervenir à sainte lucie
auprès des autorités anglaises pour que
les autorités anglaises envoie les
renforts militaires
un proche associé au fort de brégançon
fais alors incidents comme à nouveau un
incident qui a des barrages des mythes
de la milice et de l'armée l'armée ont
aidé à me laisser l'armée coloniale
armées locales si oui est ce que ce sont
les mulets de ses pieds de frau de
france et les colocs qui bloque la
montée des destructions qui se sont
enquis de son lycée il ya trois balles
je préviens ça allait c'était ce que
françois premier barrage d'accord
milices et militer au deuxième barrage
la menthe et robert et 3e âge gourmand
trinity et cette fameuse goélette qui
dans lequel celui-ci plus le magicien
qui remonte qu'à novi aplati d'air donc
après une petite semaine
la situation militaire à s'inverser
maîtriser la mélisse et l'armé au poing
l'accord le candidat l'habitation
d'obame et du nouveau au saint-esprit
d'accord le cac et pris 19 pour tout de
suite connu ensuite sa 4 heures du matin
à six autres matin le camp deuil de la
caille prix aussi donc le nombre de
morts on compte 29 officiellement mais
pendant entre le ventre le 28 septembre
le 22 septembre il le fait du septum au
moment où l'insurrection était à son
paroxysme et là que la répression
s'organise tadic vraiment une cette
partie et bien si tu as un esprit de
soutien sanitaire dieu avant gardes
historiques autour de cette zone
les miliciens et les militaires bru
toutes les casses des visites et des
cases en paille ça d'un clic terrain
tous très content des morts parce qu'il
faut voir la situation du sud vient
soudainement le diamant demande c'est
que les demandes tout est brûlé et
saccagé le nombre de morts effectivement
personne ne connaît le mot évidemment
parce que nos rigide et femmes héroïques
qui sera mis en place
ap les cieux après l'abolition de cette
avalanche était complet vous aider ça
peut les registres
d'où le nom individualités des dualités
d'accord team usa complet d'accord c'est
pas mal à personne que mandanda
officiellement en a une centaine mais en
réalité des historiens 200 et 500 et en
attendant à trouver la joueuse le
gouvernant le gouverneur de la
correspondance avec son ministre déclare
que les aigles et
le camp est le corps le corps disons
qu'en blanc a été tellement terrorisée
et qu' il se livre à une véritable
chasse à l'homme après les appels que
les troubles des songes et celui où j'ai
été traitée a été vaincu maintenant que
et il y à il ya comment dirais je
et assume il ya sur le plan de la
répression sur le plan de la rue pour is
no il y à quelques hésitations du côté
du même du gouverneur qui tous que ces
affaires il comme on dit chez nous l'an
passé paris alors il ne reste que huit
minutes on va on va tout de suite passé
quand même au procès commencé six
nations voilà et comment se sont
déroulées comment s'est déroulé le
procès y avait plusieurs attractions
plusieurs de centaines de personnes
plusieurs centaines de personnes ont été
arrêtées comment se passent les procès à
venir vont pousser fort soit il ya eu
ces 100 arrestations thème important
c'est 100 arrestations
tu as dit que tu as menée au x 2 et 7 et
enfin 2 et et au fort saint louis 700
arrestations d'accord et tout de suite
alors j'ai d'abord ce qui est important
c'est que le venin dans la lettre sa
femme et il a proclamé la bicis dans la
masse à la peau comme l'armistice enfin
les pressions se tonifier surtout oui
surtout la milice la milice et la jce
oui la mairie ce qu'était forme de
béquille
niccoli kuyek tuer les yeux de tous et
haïti doit soit être aussi parce qu'ils
savaient bien qu'anaïs ex parfait nous
venons et les colonialistes savez bien
en haïti il ya plusieurs stades de
l'insurrection il ya eu d'appel makanda
lexie et qui sait l'abolition de ce
travail merci qui ça régénérer s'adonner
l'independent haïti dont dans la tête
des des colonialistes français de
l'époque
d'accord il ne fallait pas aller trop
loin de la répétition parce qu'elle fait
bien de la colonie qu'avec la colonie
surtout ces pièces antiques
donc c'est sans arrêt sur le gouverneur
oui c'est son arrestation c'est
important cette création unique était au
bord de l indépendance c'est à ce moment
là si les agressions avaient exagéré de
dire je peux pas dire enfin les amphis
nous pas nous dire oui de fruit d'amours
exact mais quand on voit l'ampleur le du
mouvement de masse
quand on voit la répression temps qui a
été organisé et le parce qu'en fait il
n'y a pas eu un procès civil il ya le
tribunal militaire ça disons considérer
que les essieux j'ai été déçu j'ai donc
il fallait avoir un face à face édition
des éditions falloir en face un tribunal
correspondant à l'acte de guerre qu'est
ce qui fait donc il n'y a pas ce trip
d'habilité il ya eu 7
cette cession on a entre les archives
que de deux premières sessions d'accord
et lisons dans les a pas de messi sont
importantes parce que si la caution et
comme dirigeant sont jugés les
principaux chefs des sujets qu'on a cru
d'un 1ère 2ème session d'ailleurs parce
qu'il soit jugé pour goode et céramique
cinq jeux aussi pour incendies il s'agit
aussi pour voir l'expérience on les
retrouve un peu dans tous les cas c'est
exactement ces accusations ils sont et
ils seront
condamné à mort alors on peut dire tout
de suite il ya eu d'abord première
condamnation à mort il ya eu cinq jeux
donnent leur nom c'est le diffuser au
polygone et des curieux le 25 9 71
c'est jay de la caille ce dividende a
parlé puisque la bonne elle bougeait un
tube cyrulnik amant et louis-charles
août
alors cela ils ont été condamnés à mort
l'acca évidemment parce qu'ils étaient
des gens ils étaient condamnés à mort
parce que on estimait que c'était quand
même participé à l'assassinât du
directeur connaît d'accord et à des 171
j'ai encore trois exécutions
c'est pas sur l'exécution pas encore
l'écho d'un lac ou dans des morceaux
plus nombreux et je vois des ccq sion
d'accord il ya eu du sa fugue ans
bientôt 10 ch papa ils seront aussi des
x 6 x les poêler eu de fusil en main 7
au 21 décembre sur ce terreau
essentielle et d'autres condamnés un
manque n'a pas été fusillés dans la
peine a été commuée alors par contient
des condamnés à mort par contumace ainsi
qu'ils sont aussi candidats on retrouve
comme java retrouver comme d'hab on vous
comprenez il ya tel cas on sait qu'ils
baissent et que si y'a bolivar oui la
madeleine clem et il ya trois autres que
j'oublie pas citer tous les noms de même
de mémoire qui ont été confrontés eux
aussi condamnés à mort bon ensuite y en
a qui était condamné au bagne à
perpétuité un exemple ses villas c'était
si futur qui était condamné au bagne on
ne voit qu'elle donnait apb du thé
d'accord mais pas encore le bagne de
guyane cayenne guyane parce que ils
commencent simplement mais par sécurité
on les envoyait il y à il ya deux types
de habbaniya effectivement en fonction
de la peine à perpétuité mais tant que
c'est pas un peu comme ça où est pas osé
aller soleil du midi sophie était bonne
au bagne en guyane en bas ne vienne
d'accord
traçant la banane animaux donc si vous
voulez jouer pour une cause des exemples
ya eu on va quand même avancer parce que
les quatre minutes en croit aujourd'hui
on est enfin un autre saut dans le temps
en quoi aujourd'hui le 1870 et fondateur
de notre société
rarement nicolas oui les abolitions 848
avait modifié
déjà fortement la société dans ses
autres enfants du mans principales à
savoir la suppression de la propriété de
l'homme par l'homme
et on avait une société qui au fond
penser c'est parce que sa composante par
ses composants ne sera pas très
différente
paprec mission 48 on aura simplement les
esclaves qui vont devenir des hommes
libres à l'époque cherchait des
chercheurs des citoyens ou peu de temps
comme nous avons vu et il y a toujours
la classe luminox semaine cas selon mina
ce à dire la classe de l'aristocratie
sucrière blanche qui possède les
terrains qui possède les entreprises su
courir et c'est donc ce sont les mêmes
individus d'un des statuts différents
désormais puisque il y a le travail
disons libre entre guillemets où on est
et que vous décrivez par mois salaire en
principe après des négociations
l'hymne soi disant bons mais les
migrations sera immédiatement mise en
place pour casser pour casser le
mouvement et pour faire que pour obliger
les n'est gaulle devenu libre
pour les obliger à accepter les
conditions de travail qui sont faites
par les pour les propriétaires et il y a
le haut fonctionnaire de l'époque qui
est cool et ça c'est des trucs
officielle disait fait appel arrive et
des immigrés nous sommes arrivés au bout
je me sens un peu aux résultats est le
salaire est à descendre un fonds salle
elle est descendue en 1870 un acte de
résistance majeure qu'est l'enseignement
on peut en tirer aujourd'hui en 2016
jean luc sans ça ce sera le but de la
fin alors il ya deux choses
c'est la nature de la répression et la
nature du procès le procès a voulu être
exemplaire parce que lors de ce procès
il a aidé n'a pas été le bas débattu des
origines socio économiques dans la
sélection mais les sections étaient
condamnés comme une ingratitude à la
république c'est à dire au sein de la
liberté vous osez vous révolter et quand
on va bien campoli l'exacte du procès
les avocats d un sujet comme des
accusateurs ont le même discours
ce sont des scélérats ils ont voulu tuer
la colonie qui sont ce sont des egratz
et quand on regarde par exemple livres
13 et portugal il débauche de couleurs
de ce qu'est belge qui aura prendre tout
ce discours idéologique sur
l'ingratitude de cette race d'arras
d'aller nec qui sont des fainéants des
paris succédant à tous les publics
ils sont souvent qu'en même temps on les
écrase
pourquoi définitivement ya plus de
révolte dans la martinique et c'est ça
le sais ça fait partie de la sélection
qu'il faut bien comprendre du procès
c'est qu'ils ont voulu
à travers ce procès tu es la république
en tant que tel il pas briser
définitivement les martiniquais d un
homme dynamique vous vous révoltez est
dans la tête et c'est important que je
dis c'est pas celui d'un club dans la
tête des gens devient humain pendant des
années pendant des années il ya alors
viens de choses faut savoir que ajoute
on le prête en élise des enfants à la
cabaude et pour demander pardon d'avoir
du goût dit ça y est c'est fait entre
après la guerre jusqu'à les années 60
deuxièmement l'eau d'un sens du but lot
en 1911
nous les jeunes en 1979 et et de
satisfaction les gens ne le dit mais oui
10e place brûlée par saint palais league
la fa godet cette malédiction
c'était entre guillemets est clair donc
ce qui fait que contrairement à la
jamaïque où ces sujets sont devenus mono
et symboliquement et c'était exactement
chez nous non cette insurrection qui
s'est un majeur qui le plus important
que mu à 48 et 2d est passé dans la
trappe de l'histoire il dit juste un mot
pour chacun disait d'ailleurs des
insurgés qui s'étaient détériorées à la
fin des séries en effet comptable il y a
plusieurs livres qui s'ils auront
l'instruction que vont donc ont trouvé
toutes les références sur notre site
la première point fr donc le livre de
gilbert fabre dont nous avons parlé le
livre d'armand nicolas évidemment qui a
été le premier à écrire et puis le livre
de l'historienne française basée à
bordeaux unique membre très important
également
merci messieurs cette émission est
terminée jean louis foncièrement nicolas
merci vous étiez vous invitez je marque
partie inertie face à la première été
réalisé par gilles luisi et adele qui
kelly merci bon appétit vous êtes si
vous êtes à table à 13h retrouver
fabrice de frais non merci